[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau séduit les invités
voici les titres l'université versailles
saint quentin en fête ses 25 ans jeudi 8
juin plusieurs animations sont prévues
pour l'occasion
nous serons sur le plateau fabienne miss
guichou hill vice présidente en charge
de la vie universitaire et chef de
projet du ghana nom débute ce 7,8 des
invités avec madame alary jean principal
du collège le village et monsieur
l'arbitré here conseiller municipal à
trappes ils organisent samedi 10 joints
à la conquête des métiers des métiers le
but aider des jeunes à s'orienter après
le brevet je ne me suis pas trompé non
alors pourquoi vous avez mis en place
cet événement dites moi alors que depuis
quelques années la trappe on organisait
ce qu'on appelait avant les soirées la
cerise indiqué l'exemple l'objectif
c'était sur la base davos et sur le sur
la demande des jeunes de réunir des
professionnels de tous corps de métier
pour échanger avec eux et on faisait en
général le vendredi soir avec un public
qui pouvait toucher des sixièmes jusqu'à
des étudiants parfois en des élèves de
terminale
donc on avait une très grande dispersion
et cela se fait sous forme de speed
dating donc c'est vrai que les plus âgés
avaient tendance à poser des questions
qui prenaient plus de temps il y avait
un échange plus construire avec eux et
donc la progressivement on a décidé avec
les chefs d'établissements d'organiser
une session spécifique pour les élèves
de 4e parce que c'est quand même en
quatrième que l'on demande en des
premières voilà les premières
orientations et du cou
décidez donc d'opérer cette
collaboration qui j'espère sera
fructueuse
c'est vraiment un besoin sur le
territoire est vraiment des jeunes de
plus en plus qui sont perdus à cette
période de leur vie
c'est un très gros besoin parce que que
ce soit sur le territoire ou ailleurs
lorsqu'on demande un jeune de 13 ou 14
ans de se projeter sur l'avenir lui se
projette à une semaine seulement je
pense aux 20 mètres c'est très compliqué
quand même de se dire qu'on va
construire un parcours à cette époque là
or quand ensuite les choses en troisième
s'accélère parce qu'il gère à la fois la
préparation de l'examen du lycée de
l'orientation c'est déjà un peu tard et
pour certains c'est une source de stress
énorme donc se dire que en 4e lui
commence à les faire se projeter mais en
les accompagnant c'est à dire on ne les
jette pas dans le vide à mions dit on va
essayer de leur faire prendre conscience
qu'il y a des possibles eh ben c'est
l'enjeu de cette opération là ça se
passe comment ces événements alors enfui
sur l'opération on a en fait plusieurs
métiers dont qui vont être présentés aux
jeunes sous forme de speed dating en
fait on va avoir différentes salles de
classe où on a regroupé donc les métiers
du droit les métiers de l'hôtellerie les
métiers autour des animaux de
l'automobile et l'idée c'est leur
montrer que derrière un corps de métier
se cachent plusieurs métiers l'idée
c'est de susciter des vocations
je sais pas ce qu'il ya à côté
l'officier
nos terres l'idée c'est vraiment aussi
de lutter contre l'autocensure c'est dur
à nos jeunes trappistes ici en
l'occurrence de vous vous êtes
intéressés par les métiers par exemple
de l'hôtellerie ou de la santé où les
forces de l'ordre voilà tous les corps
de métiers et par exemple sur la santé
on va leur présenter un médecin
potentiellement mais l'aide soignante et
l'infirmière et on va essayer de 1 peut
désenclaver cette censure qui est un
barrage en fait pour leur construction
personnelle et professionnelle ils sont
beaucoup à voir cette autocensure c'est
vrai que moi même au moment de mon
orientation je me voyais pas ici ou même
journaliste c'est pourquoi cette censure
là elles sont passées il ya passé deux
il ya une censure dont le vécu familial
parce que on est quand même sur une
population sur trappe
globalement défavorisés on est quand
même à plus de 60% de catégories
socioprofessionnelles défavorisées donc
c'est pas immédiats de penser à certains
métiers
et c'est vrai que l'ambition du coup
c'est quelque chose qui est à développer
qui a développé au sein de l'école or
les familles nous font vraiment
confiance pour ça mais en même temps il
ya des moments où nous disent nous on ne
peut pas on ne sait pas donc c'est
important de questionner les jeunes et
on a vraiment fait une démarche de
projet à l'échelle des trois collèges
sur les métiers qui pouvait les
intéresser et en fonction de leurs
réponses on a construit donc 11 au
secteur avec chaque fois trois ou quatre
professionnels qui vont venir présenter
des métiers qui ont trait à ce secteur
en faisant aussi attention à promouvoir
l'égalité filles garçons parce qu'on a
aussi ça se dire que des filles peuvent
exercer des métiers traditionnellement
masculins qui se veulent masculin et
inversement
des sommes qui peuvent présenter des
métiers de la santé en étant autre chose
que médecin il ya des infirmiers donc ça
c'est quand même crucial de se dire que
les familles et les jeunes vont pouvoir
commencer à discuter avec des gens qui
vont leur expliquer quelle a été leur
parcours est aussi qu'il n'ya pas une
voie royale que l'on peut arriver à ses
fins en ayant plusieurs carrières ou en
ayant eu des ruptures quelquefois qui
ont été nécessaires pour envisager une
nouvelle reprise d'études
aujourd'hui vous pensez qu'il ya pas
assez de professionnels qui passent dans
les collèges montrer tout ça aux élèves
il ya le côté
oui un petit enfant défavorisé mais
aussi ce côté les élèves savent pas
qu'ils en pensent comment est le monde
de l'entreprise
très clairement la l'idée aussi si le
fait de veiller à informer ça veut dire
que là les jeunes ne vont pas être
forcément dans leur classe avec leur
prof et leurs professeurs ils vont être
mélangés ça va être c'est surtout les
jeunes de la ville donc de c'est un
échange qui est beaucoup plus
intelligent intéressant tant pour le
collaborateur d'entreprise qui va venir
présenter son métier que pour le jeune
qui va être là et qui va pouvoir reposer
en toute liberté ces questions parce
qu'il va pas être devant ses camarades
de classe devant le professeur devant
l'institution que peut représenter
parfois le collège en soi et bien je
vous remercie d'être venu sur le plateau
vous restez avec nous et j'espère que
votre événement va fonctionner c'est
important
l'université de versailles saint quentin
à 25 ans demain plusieurs animations
sont prévues pour l'occasion pour en
parler nous recevons sur le plateau
fabienne miss guiche chef de projet du
gala
bonsoir 25 ans oui déjà dit j'ai
effectivement l'université né le 22
juillet 1991 par un décret ainsi que
trois autres universités s'étaient
plaints université 2000
et donc voilà nous voulions fêter cet
événement
donc ça et tout un tas d'événements taux
tombe tout au long de l'année
hélas cette fois-ci demain c'est le jour
de la géorgie alors comment il va se
dérouler aujourd'hui alors ce jour j
alors peut-être d'abord créé explique un
petit peu le cadrage qu'on voulait faire
donc
donc l'idée c'était d'organiser auquel
un événement festif évidemment qui nous
permettent de nous rassembler à la fois
les personnels administratifs les
enseignants chercheurs les étudiants
actuels mais aussi à l'umih parce qu'en
fait nos diplômés sont très demandeurs
de revenir à l'université ce sont nos
ambassadeurs
donc ça c'était c'était très important
le dans la deuxième lettre et de nous
rassembler puisque on couvre tout le
territoire et donc on a décidé de faire
cet événement festif à versailles
l ufr des sciences donc la deuxième
point de cette lettre de cadrage était
de favoriser le portage étudiants et
donc je vais vous l'expliquer dans
quelques instants et ça ça va
fonctionner aussi bien pour une
conférence tedx que pour l'organisation
du gala on est là derrière en back up
mais c'est vraiment portés par des
étudiants et surtout c'est la première
fois qu'on fait un événement comme ça où
on associe le personnel et les étudiants
ce qui était un pari le pari visiblement
a marché puisque on a dû surbooké on est
complet et donc ça c'était l'origine
complètement et ça c'est l originalité
un petit peu de ce projet et l'idée
enfin c'était de retracer ses 25 ans
mais aussi de montrer notre maturité
dont notre coeur de métier c'est là
c'est l'enseignement c'est la recherche
mais montrer aussi le plaisir qu'on a
tous à travailler ensemble
donc voilà donc ça va s'organiser de
cette façon donc c'est surtout
l'après-midi tout d'abord va y avoir une
conférence tedx donc ça c'est des
étudiants qui porte ce projet qu'ont eu
la licence tedx et une licence
américaine donc une naissance tedx uv
est ce qu a dit rapidement pour maladie
six mois voilà c'est ce sont des
conférences données par des spécialistes
mais pour tout public et donc ils ont eu
comme la belle
ils ont ils ont proposé donc
invisibilité mais essentiel et donc ils
font venir des spécialistes sur ce thème
notamment quelqu'un qui va venir nous
parler de l'adn qui est vraiment la
machinerie interne des cellules il va
nous parler aussi de management c'est
invisible mais c'est essentiel qui va
aussi nous parler du wi fi par la
lumière donc c'est invisible mais sans
wifi on est un petit peu un petit peu
bloquée ça devient compliqué donc ça on
est très fier parce que c'est vraiment
un projet voilà portés par des étudiants
de l'institut supérieur du management
donc ça c'est intéressant ensuite y aura
un tournoi sportif ça s'est organisée
par le service des sports où on organise
voilà des compétitions pareil étudiants
personnels de badminton en double et
enfin une cérémonie à partir de 17h donc
là on aura une période de discours avec
évidemment des politiques et ensuite on
a le plaisir donc patrice carmouze a
accepté d'animer cette série voilà que
vous connaissez bien ici d'animer cette
cérémonie
donc ça va être des petits pitch de
quelques minutes qui vont nous permettre
de retracer notre histoire mais aussi de
le montrer voilà où on en est et donc de
2 voilà de montrer notre niveau de
maturité
enfin il y aura un buffet donc là notre
partenaire le crous qui s'occupe de la
restauration dans les établissements du
supérieur bien participé à ce but fait
et ensuite on aura un fameux gala donc
la legal apportées par les étudiants à
nouveau c'est eux qu'on trouvait le dj
c'est eux qui s'occupent de tout
l'organisation de l'accueil à part d'ubs
a préféré garder le cap
messieurs mais voilà et donc on fait
venir un dj qui est assez connue donc le
groupe jabberwocky et donc voilà ça
fonctionne bien aussi mais ça c'est
demain soir vous avez dit qu'il ya
beaucoup d'élèves qui ne sont plus
aujourd'hui à l'université qui vont
contribuer à cette journée au bout de 25
ans il ya quand même des liens donc qui
se sont tissés tout à fait alors il ya
des liens parce que notamment nous avons
un cluster donc sur ce cluster sont
inscrits les anciens diplômés qui
forment un réseau qui indique dans
quelle entreprise il travaille est donc
ce réseau en fête permet à des jeunes
diplômés d'aller voir s'il ya quelqu'un
dans une entreprise par la gauche répond
cité mais voir s'il ya un ancien du vs
cul s'il ya un ancien du ps qu il peut
le contacter directement par ce cluster
et lui demander comment s'est passé
l'entretien comment et l'entreprise est
d'ailleurs par rapport à ça il ya
plusieurs événements qui ont été faits
ou des professionnels en s'offrant des
anciens de libé ce qui revenait du rang
des forums orienté et donc là il y aura
des ambassadeurs qui vont venir sur
scène et qui vont et parce qu'il ya
aussi des ambassadeurs qui sont amusés à
rechercher des diplômés du vs cul qui
n'était pas forcément sur le cluster
donc il ya ça on va le montrer mais on
va voilà aussi montré des étudiants qui
sont passés qui était apprenti a lu vs
cul qui sont sur ce qu'ils sont sortis
voilà ce qu'ils ont fait voilà est-ce
que leur a permis de faire me vs cul
voilà non voilà quand j'étais en train
de penser dans les anciens on a aussi
quelqu'un vous parliez de trappes qui
vient d'autres appétits qui voit là
c'est un beau témoignage qui dit lu vs q
c'était un ascenseur social je ne
connaissais pas les codes je suis arrivé
en fac de droit et lu vs cuba m'a permis
de passer une marche supérieure et donc
ce sera de ce genre aussi de témoignages
que no more et pour finir très
rapidement c'est quoi l'avenir de
l'université après ses 25 ans un ou deux
projets un peu l'avenir bon évidemment
la question de paris saclay un comment
tout ça va va s'articuler mais aussi
notre position sur le territoire nous on
ne déménage pas sur le plateau de saclay
donc nous on a toujours cette se voit là
cet ancrage dans le territoire que l'on
évidemment que l'on défend aussi et bien
deux beaux événements à venir
vous irez est ce que vous vous y
réaliser à tout à fait et on s'intéresse
évidemment aussi à l'insertion
professionnelle on a aussi une seule
mercenariat on a des partenariats et
bien très bien
au fait la france 7,8 les invités merci
de nous avoir suivis et surtout bonne
soirée
[Musique]